while more than 100 students getting
sick at an elementary school after
numerous reports of students vomiting
but as of now we still don't know what
caused it it happened Friday at Wayne
and Tanaka Elementary School near Fort
Apache and Warm Springs Ryan Matthey has
been covering their story he joins us
now live with more on what he's learned
right
Denise O'Brien it happened in the
hallways right behind us here parents
say in masses students were lined
outside the health office all with one
similar condition on Friday that's
intense vomiting so was that passed
along from another student could have
been passed along from cafeteria food
parents don't know but they do want
answers
our students teacher told us that it was
like the apocalypse John and Danielle
Farrow picked up their child from Wayne
and Tanaka Elementary Friday afternoon
unaware of what happened just Behind
These Walls the teacher said it was like
Armageddon she said there were our
daughters said that there were trash
cans lined up and kids just throwing up
everywhere their child's class of 20
down to nearly half by the end of the
day they say after those sick were sent
home an 8 news now Source close to the
matter adds that around 130 students
rapidly began showing signs of sickness
and were throwing up in masses this is
what the school sent parents saying the
Southern Nevada Health District was
investigating a gastrointestinal illness
reported by several students but what
was it and how did students get it
their questions we are waiting for
answers on from the school district
parents speculate it was from cafeteria
food the day prior the Southern Nevada
Health District telling 8 news now that
gastrointestinal viruses can be spread
by eating drinking or touching
contaminated food or surfaces the 8 news
now soars saying to school never shut
down and parents still don't know
specifics days later as if one person
gets sick in our household everybody
gets sick and they're sharing a
classroom most of the day together so I
see how it could happen
now the health district tells us it's
still very early in this investigation
not a lot to add at this point but when
we talk to the school district we ask
them how many students were involved how
many students were sent home and again
could this have all been a food
poisoning situation those questions
remain unanswered reporting live outside
Tanaka Elementary in Spring Valley Ryan
Matthey 8 News Now